in his first podcast episode
since we learned that at least Donald
Trump thinks he's about to get arrested
Donald Trump Jr delivered
a manic episode seemingly about what is
happening with his dad I've never seen
Junior like this and I've seen Junior
pretty hopped up he also seems to have
developed like a new accent for his
podcast where he speaks in an
extraordinarily strange way and his show
is called triggered which is very very
uh apropos of his demeanor here take a
look at this who really gives a crap
about law when you're a weapon
weapon your office in a leftist state
and where everyone there agrees with you
most of the project is there don't know
what
what most radical of the radical left
isn't this the most bizarre delivery
realize that it's insane all fairness
like isn't she like paying his legal
bills or something like that
I don't know but you know the district
attorney is going to district attorney
right the Soros funded District
Attorneys are gonna do whatever the guy
that's Bank rolling them wants them to
do the law be damned the Constitution be
damned your rights be Dan because you
know when you hate America what
difference does it make this prosecution
isn't based on facts or the law or
anything that even resembles that it's
how would he know that pure Bolshevik
style witch hunter the hot take on
Twitter was that these guys are trying
to do this this was the hot stupid take
on Twitter over the weekend like the
dumbest take ever that they're trying to
do this to make sure it trumps the
nominee like they weren't trying to put
him in jail for the last eight years
like they didn't accuse me and the rest
of my family of treason and other things
okay and then at another moment I guess
ostensibly Junior on this episode was
interviewing Ronnie Jackson the
Republican congressman who used to be
Trump's doctor and again it's like it's
not really an interview because junior
is just ranting uncontrollably you know
as you know I had a really good
relationship with a lot of guys on my
secret service detail like so much so
that they moved guys off of my detail
because they were like oh you're too
comfortable with this I was like I
promise you guys like you want me
comfortable with my guys because if
something goes wrong like I I'm the guy
that thinks I'm always right like I get
that like I want to like the guy because
I'll trust him a lot everybody knew you
had more guns anyway yeah we won't even
get into that one clearly uh clearly so
you know we had a good time but you know
the one sort of thing and you know four
years of you know guys rotating in and
out I mean that was the one thing they
said with you you know you took care of
those guys too uh you know when they
were going on International trips when
they were pulling multiple day type
understand that what Junior is doing now
is saying Ronnie Jackson as Trump's
doctor would give sleeping medication to
Secret Service agents that that's really
the the core of what he is praising him
for here spiders you were the guy that
took care of everything that they ever
needed and did so so professionally uh
those guys love you yeah and you know
that stuff means so much more to me than
if the boss likes you right you know
when the guys they you know you could
blow off right you know I don't need to
pay attention yeah he's the lowly
whatever he's not high up on the totem
pole he can't help my promotion or my
career right you know when those guys
are a huge fan you know that's when I'm
like okay yeah now I I respect it so
much more and so watching that attack on
you right again a rear Admiral uh
obviously served in the Navy just a
bizarre bizarre show all together and
maybe the most interesting thing about
the Don Jr show on Rumble is that it in
the last three to five days has taken a
decidedly anti-run DeSantis perspective
and that's what I want to briefly look
at next